dune is a beloved sci-fi epic involving
space travel giant sand worms and
high-stakes games of politics on a
galactic scale at the center of this is
one legendary family house atreides
we're here to break down this storied
clan from their mythical origins to
their strange
star-strewn legacy
it is said that the atreides clan can
trace their lineage back to the mythical
king agamemnon a major player in the
trojan war who appears in the odyssey
and the iliad agamemnon was the son of
king atreyus from which atreides is
derived this connection to legendary
kings queens and heroes is apparent in
the way the atreides family carries
themselves agamemnon led the greek
armies against troy and the atreides of
dune are similarly warlike while they
seem at first glance to maintain a
balance with nature and a healthy fear
of industrialization on the planets they
control make no mistake
their armies are still feared as fierce
and accomplished fighters they fight
often enough to have created their own
battle language a series of hand signals
to be used in conflict
just as their ancestor commanded
legendary forces in the ancient world so
too do they among the stars
by the time readers meet the atreides
family of dune they are far away from
greece house of tradies oversees kaladan
a lush planet covered in forests and
seas that is part of the galactic
patterson empire they are fair rulers
who take conservatorship of their planet
very seriously the people of kaladan are
largely satisfied and well cared for on
their planet living in harmony with
nature the atreides family is forced to
leave their homeworld behind however
when the emperor commands them to take
control of the desert planet arrakis
also known as dune this hostile planet
is a desert world where water is
punishingly scarce
humans religious refugees known as
fremen have lived on the planet for
centuries
they have adapted to the planet's harsh
surface by living underground and
building a society geared towards the
conservation of water
and when we have enough
[Music]
we shall change the face of arrakis
the pasha empire's interest in dune is
peaked by the discovery of a critical
resource the planet is the only known
source of the spice melange a fragrant
commodity found under the sand that
gives people who ingested
mild prescience
the spice as it is known is a crucial
component of religious ceremonies and
light speed navigation and its highly
addictive nature leaves the empire with
no choice but to take control of the
planet prior to the treaty's arrival the
planet was ruled by the harkonnens long
time rivals of the atreides the arkonans
are ruthless and greedy their homeworld
having been turned into a smog choked
hell in service of increasing profits
the harkonnens launch a plot with the
emperor to take down the atreides who
are wildly popular leaders that the
galactic ruler seized as a threat to his
own throne the harkonnen's time on
arrakis allows them to set traps for the
incoming family ideally in the emperor's
mind this will make the defeat of the
eutrades look like inter-house rivalry
he loans his incredibly gifted force of
soldiers and disguises them in harkonnen
uniforms
sympathetic people within the conspiracy
warned the atreides family over the trap
laid for them duke leto atreides and
many of his men are killed in the attack
but his son paul and paul's mother
jessica are able to escape
both paul and jessica have been trained
in the ways of the benny jesuit and used
their powers of observation and coercion
to survive the desert
paul is eventually taken in by a band of
fremen they are initially wary of paul
and jessica but their gifts of
prescience courtesy of the spice and
paul's unique abilities collide with
prophecies seated among the fremen by
benny jessuret missionaries
paul's goals to take back the planet
coincide with the freman's belief that
they will someday rise up and take back
control of their home as paul and
jessica learn to survive in the desert
word of paul's god-like powers spread
among the fremen and a plot is hatch to
cast out imperial forces
jessica's arrival among the fremen is
particularly well-timed she has been
trained in the ways of the beni jesuit
an order of women who secretly pull the
strings of galactic power their leaders
are known as reverend mothers and the
freman's own reverend is nearing the end
of her life the freeman believed jessica
would make a suitable replacement but to
become a reverend mother one must drink
the water of life a poison derived from
the sand worms who live on doom high
level benny jester members have such
intense control of their bodies that
they can isolate the poison inside
themselves and render it harmless
if they fail
they die if survived however the water
of life opens up a mental pathway
connecting the survivor to the memories
of all the reverend mothers who came
before her jessica is pregnant when she
undergoes the water of life ceremony as
a result her unborn daughter aaliyah
absorbs this knowledge alongside her
mother the benny jessrite know that
people born with this knowledge already
awakened before they can form
personalities of their own are uniquely
unstable they view these children as
deeply cursed abominations
jessica and paul refused to cast her out
and aaliyah becomes an incredibly
important figure in the years following
her older brother's crusade
having been shaped by their uniquely
dangerous landscape the freemen are some
of the fiercest fighters in the galaxy
paul season them a resource that can be
used to take on the emperor's
universally feared soldiers he trains
the fremen in atreides battle techniques
and the body control of the benny
jesterate creating a desert-wide army of
super soldiers together they prepare for
an attack on the planet's imperial
capital arakin
during his time outside of the empire's
reach paul also realizes the unique
power the controller of dune wields they
are the controller of spice production
the most coveted resource in the
universe necessary for travel between
planets and highly addictive to boot
whoever controls the spice controls the
entire universe thus paul uses a dual
strategy of direct attack and threat to
the production of spice to bring down
the galactic empire we must totally
destroy all spice production on arrakis
paul sets up his soldiers in the desert
outside arakin using a storm as cover
when the storm lifts they launch a
brutal assault on the capital to keep
imperial reinforcements off the planet
paul threatens to destroy the spice
something all space navigators require
to do their jobs and keep on living as
withdrawal can be fatal the emperor
concedes control to paul and he launches
a cosmic jihad to bring all known worlds
under his rule
after paul becomes the emperor the
gospel of paula tradies begins to grow
the capital of arakeen becomes a holy
city with churches and cults based
around paul and his sister aliyah
but though the empire continues to
expand
rot sets in back home
fremont veterans become disillusioned
with emperor tradies cause
terraforming has begun on dune to make
it a more habitable planet and the old
ways of water conservation are slipping
powerful forces that have been
embarrassed by paul's sudden rise
exploit this discontent and hatch a plot
against the emperor emperor atreides is
blinded by a nuclear attack on arrakis
but retains his ability to see via his
incredible gifts of prescience the
emperor's blindness further rankles his
friend followers however who expect
people who have been blinded to walk
into the desert to die rather than
burden their tribe after fathering two
children with channy paul appears to
sacrifice himself in the traditional
fashion solidifying his status as a
god-like figure among his subjects and
fremen followers alike
paul's sister aaliyah takes on the
duties of running the eutrades empire
expecting to serve as regent until
paul's children grow to adulthood
aaliyah pulls power to herself rather
than turn the throne over creating her
own cult and surrounding herself with
die hards eventually however her own
strange birth catches up with her her
unstable personality succumbs to one of
the countless other selves in her memory
and she begins to be possessed by a
treaty's enemy vladimir harkonnen when a
mystical preacher from the desert
appears believed to be her brother the
harkonnen aliyah fears her rule will be
overturned and orders his death leto ii
who has been living among the fremen
returns for his self-imposed exile and
orders alia to stand trial for crimes
against the eu treaty's empire she
breaks free of harkonnen's hold long
enough to end her own life in the
aftermath letter ii forces the
development of humanity across his
empire to suit his goal he reigns for 3
500 years before realizing that he
ultimately must die for the next stage
of humanity to develop
letter ii sets about preparing for his
death he carries on the atreides
bloodline via distant relatives despite
the fact that many of them have no idea
they're part of the legendary house he
reverses the complete terraforming of
dune returning it to the harsh desert it
once was
finally he allows himself to die in an
ambush thereby ending the atreides
empire in the chaotic period following
the death of leto ii his empire
fractures and splits into millions of
independent worlds in what becomes known
as the scattering forcing the further
evolution of humanity according to
letter ii's plan the planets that
survive indeed flourish on their own
unique terms and the galaxy continues
into infinity
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
bye